hold up à la gare de l'est fric frac à
la caisse de retraite de la sncf
ce pourrait être les sous titre de ce
film que tourne actuellement bernard
blier jean lefebvre michel serrault et
il à shelton titre du film c'est pas
parce qu'on a rien à dire qu'il faut
fermer sa gueule date de sortie dans les
salles parisiennes décembre 74 christian
clavier gérard jugnot deux auteurs venus
du café théâtre en ont écrit le scénario
validé sur le dup
ce n'était plus parce que à partir du
lieu en fait beaucoup d'autres choses
c'est un lieu qui nous semblait
intéressant pour qui s'y passe des
choses
regardez les skis en dessous de la gare
de l'est sont les héros les toilettes ça
ça nous a inspirés et alors on a voulu
faire quelque chose dans ce lieu là si
on dirait qu'on sait sur une table ça
pour être vrai
oui réalisateur du film jacques besnard
pour lui doit déjà grand restaurant la
belle affaire et le fou du labo cats
avec déjà le trio bernard blier michel
ayrault et jean le fait il donne ici
quelques derniers conseils avant le
tournage d'une scène
public par rapport à la balade
non sans mal
ce
a qu'une solution c'est le métro
à michel théron calé au troll que je
peux y jouer vous dans ce film qu'est ce
que je fais
non franchement je réponds je t'amène
plus tard cependant le fond je m'appelle
max c'est tout ce que je sais je suis
embauché par
embauché par monsieur phal au fait tout
ce que j'ai bien la vie vous êtes le
cerveau de
laroche et beaucoup d'erreurs mais
imaginez là bas
un hold up un peu particulier on s'y
sont trois malheureux type en un hold up
très important combien en frais
avec la dévaluation et le sait pas
exactement quand monsieur nous sortira
on peux pas vous dire exactement ce que
ça donnera mais c'est beaucoup d'argent
venez et capuche et qui faisait rire et
habiller jean lefebvre pas loin d'un
milliard pour la femme une femme tout
juste un petit peu le sol dans ça vous
fait rien je vais vous dire franchement
je crois qu'ils m'ont mis au point du
scénario je croyais que c'était un court
métrage sur les guerres parce qu'on va
tourner un gars de l'est gare du nord
gare saint-lazare gare montparnasse
j'avais les yeux les invalides en fait
forcé voilà le violent sérieusement
c'est un film x en ville basse qui sera
dans gmail
d'abord devait il ne le fait pas l'air
de moi parce que je suis dedans ça sera
très long parce que ya du suspense il ya
de la poésie et que j'attende elle ya
delattre beaucoup de temps reste clément
et pour une fois y'a pas de cul ce qui
est très important à l'heure actuelle
vous pouvez lui écrire un peu votre
personnage c'est un tendre vers cambrai
malfaiteurs comme oui mais c'est un
cadre malfaiteurs qui veut soulager la
société
il veut soulager la sncf ces vidéos
qu'ils ont dans leur corps alors il
avec ses milliers qui est la tête témoin
le temps et moi le tronçon gère encore
on fauche mais c'est à elle de passer
assez particulier ce sera un très beau
film ça sera pas dit il
comique est branché sur un film que
qu'on n'aura jamais vu en plein coeur
des présidents voyez ce qu'il est accusé
d outrage envers ses fans idiote
entre temps passe et normatif et paris
nous allons chercher une dépanneuse pour
ivresse couleur bleue penny fois par
jour qu'est ce qu'il à votre véhicule
c'est
la cwa les clés